[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian Sievers guten Abend
ihnen Karsamstag 2023 und ebenso
traditionell wie mit ganz aktuellem
Anliegen waren heute in etwa 70
deutschen Städten mehrere tausend
Menschen auf der Straße
Ostermärsche für den Frieden für einen
Stillstand der Waffen in der Ukraine und
während sich über den Weg dahin heftig
streiten lässt treibt die Sorge um die
Weltlage nach dem russischen Überfall
auf das Nachbarland nicht nur die
Demonstranten heute um Molly lau
berichtet
in Hannover beginnt der traditionelle
Ostermarsch in der ausgebormten
Aegidienkirche sie wurde durch
Luftangriffe im Zweiten Weltkrieg
zerstört ihre Ruine dient als Mahnmal
für die Opfer von Kriegen und Gewalt ein
Ende der Gewalt fordern die
Demonstranten mit einer prominenten
Unterstützerin Margot kessmann Hannovers
frühere Bischöfin fordert sogar ein Ende
der westlichen Waffenlieferungen an die
Ukraine
im ganzen Land heute wollen nicht dass
die Eskalation weitergetrieben werden
wird und noch mehr Waffen ins
Kriegsgebiet geliefert werden denn mit
diesen Waffenlieferungen so hat es sehr
Philosoph Jürgen Habermas eindrücklich
herausgearbeitet damit werden wir
mitverantwortlich für all die Toten die
Theologin hat mit anderen Prominenten
zusammen einen Appell unterzeichnet der
einen Waffenstillstand und
Friedensverhandlungen mit russland
fordert diese Appell Frieden schaffen
ist umstritten wurde dafür auch
kritisiert
zum einen bekomme ich immer wieder
diffamierende äußerungen wie
lumpenpazifistin und putinversteherinnen
und anderes mehr aber in letzter Zeit
sind es mehr und mehr Botschaften und
E-Mails von Menschen die sagen Danke ich
bin froh dass diese Stimme die
gegenwaffenlieferungen sich äußert auch
Gehör findet in Deutschland die
Friedensbewegung in Deutschland ist
gespalten es gibt nicht mehr die eine
Bewegung in manchen aufrufen wird
Russland klar als Aggressor benannt
andere werfen der NATO vor Schuld am
Krieg zu sein es ist nicht ein bisschen
zynisch jetzt ähm also Pazifismus und
Frieden zu fordern werden in der Ukraine
die Menschen angegriffen werden die
werden die sterben aber doch gerade
durch die Waffen die wir liefern die
andere liefern ich möchte dass Menschen
nicht mehr sterben müssen sofort und da
ist der einzige Weg Verhandlungen sehen
sie wirklich durch Waffenlieferung ein
Weg in Richtung Frieden und Sterben auf
beiden Seiten Menschen und sie sterben
durch Waffen
und solange Menschen durch Waffen
sterben sollten wir aufhören Waffen zu
liefern sie werden den Frieden nicht
bringen in Berlin gab es mit 2000
Teilnehmern den größten Ostermarsch
darunter auch eine ukrainische
Demonstration unter dem Motto ohne
Freiheit kein Frieden
in diesen können wir nicht ja ohne
Freiheit kein Frieden dorthin wo immer
noch dieser Krieg tobt mitten in Europa
gucken wir jetzt in die Ukraine zu
meinem Kollegen daran Hass
der Weg zu einem Ende des Krieges wie
wird der in der Ukraine selbst gesehen
ja heute bei meinem Gesprächen mit den
Menschen in der Stadt und ich war die
ganze Tag unterwegs weil war der Tenor
klar Verhandlungen will die Mehrheit
hier nicht ganz eindrücklich hat mir
Svetlana aus rakev ihre Meinung
geschildert sie ist geflüchtet und seit
einem Jahr lebt sie auf der Flucht sie
sagte stell dir vor jemand kommt in dein
Haus zerschlägt alles terrorisiert und
tötet deine Liebsten und dann sollst du
mit demjenigen besprechen wie die Zimmer
Aufteilungen in deinem Haus ist nee das
will sie nicht und die ukrainische
Regierung ist eigentlich auch ganz klar
was die Frage der Verhandlungen angeht
im Moment sind sie ausgeschlossen zwei
sind in den letzten Tagen im politischen
Diskurs das Wort Verhandlungen
aufgetaucht und das ließ auch aufhorchen
aber das waren nur Gedankenspiele vor
allem wenn man bedenkt dass sie jetzt
eine große Offensive vorbereitet wird
und das moderne und viele schwere Waffen
jetzt gerade hier angekommen sind
Kredit ausgebildeten Soldaten es bleiben
Gedankenspiele Verhandlungen hier in
Kiew Stimmen und Stimmungen aus der
Ukraine daran hat unser dsdf Kiew
herzlichen Dank
um dem harten Winter zu entkommen war
Thailand immer schon beliebte
Destination für viele Russen aber was
dort aktuell passiert stellt alles
bisher da gewesene in den Schatten der
Flughafen Phuket zählt aus keinem
anderen Land so viele Fluggäste wie aus
Russland mit großem Abstand das hat
Folgen der Immobilienmarkt ist chaotisch
mittlerweile die Preise gehen durch die
Decke denn viele der Gäste aus Russland
wollen so schnell nicht mehr zurück für
sie ist der tritt nach Thailand auch
Ticket in ein neues Leben Norman
Odenthal mit mehr dazu
Hochsaison auf Phuket massenanflug aufs
Paradies auch die Aeroflot aus Moskau
trifft ein eine von acht Maschinen aus
Russland an diesem Tag André Kiril
Dimitri werden erwartet es ist 40 Grad
wärmer als zu Hause die dicken Jacken
brauchen Sie nicht aber Geld brauchen
sie thailändische Bart russische
Kreditkarten sind im Ausland gesperrt
und Rubel werden nicht genommen halt so
wild sagt er sie hätten in Moskau ihre
Hobel in US-Dollar getauscht und ihn nun
hier in Bad kein Problem
ein Visum gibt es on arrival also nach
Ankunft auch kein Problem vom Krieg an
den Strand das geht also doch einfach
aber fühlt es sich auch so an
wir waren unsicher wie uns die Menschen
im Ausland begegnen wir sind davon
ausgegangen dass es schwierig wird dass
man uns Fragen stellt auf die wir keine
Antworten haben was ist wenn wir auf
Ukrainer treffen
genaue Zahlen gibt es nicht aber gefühlt
kommen derzeit 90% aller Gäste aus
Russland sie prägen das Strandbild
Thailand hat harte Zeiten hinter sich
Pandemie wie überall für ein Land das
vom Tourismus lebt war Null Tourismus
kaum zu ertragen aber hat das Geschäft
mit den Russen einen bei Geschmack oder
ist die Frage moralisch überheblich
Phukets tourismus-chef sieht das so boah
jetzt krieg ist internationale Politik
wissen Sie und ich bin ein lokaler
Geschäftsmann für mich sind alle
willkommen auf Phuket wenn ich
Außenminister wäre würde ich vielleicht
etwas anderes sagen
Thailands Regierung will neutral sein
heißt keine Verurteilung Moskaus keine
Sanktionen das zahlt sich wohl aus auch
langfristig Phuket Bauboom hängt nicht
zuletzt an russischer Nachfrage
russischem Geld besonders das
Luxussegment läuft draußen wird auf
Russisch geworden und drinnen sind
russische Maklerinnen gut im Geschäft
die Boxschule mitten in Pattaya ist wie
eine russische Exklave hier Boxen große
kleine Touristen Einwohner es sind fast
ausnahmslos Russen
Nikita 32 Rechtsanwalt aus Moskau
gekommen vor zwei Monaten gekommen um zu
bleiben eine bewusste Flucht vor dem
Regime der Armee den Krieg
ja das ist so ich weiß dass das Militär
schon vor meiner Wohnung stand um mich
einzuziehen 5 Uhr morgens haben sie mit
ihren Stiefeln gegen die Tür getreten
vielleicht wäre ich jetzt in der Ukraine
sagt er vielleicht wäre ich schon tot
aber Nikita lebt boxt sich durch jetzt
in Thailand
die ersten Speisekarten auf Russisch und
die ersten britischen Touristen
beschweren sich bereits die haben hier
alles übernommen
unsere Nachrichtenübersicht jetzt mit
die 1 wenige Tage nach dem USA Besuch
der taiwanesischen Präsidentin sei eng
wenn hat das chinesische Militär ein
Manöver rundum Taiwan begonnen es sei
eine Warnung an diejenigen die sich für
eine Unabhängigkeit der Insel einsetzen
das tawanistische
Verteidigungsministerium zählte neuen
chinesische Kriegsschiffe und 71
Militärflugzeuge die Volksrepublik
betrachtet das demokratisch regierte
Taiwan als chinesisches Territorium
zeitgleich zu der Militärübung empfing
die taiwanesische Präsidentin in Taipeh
eine Delegation von
US-Abgeordneten
nach den Anschlägen in Israel gestern
und wegen der insgesamt angespannten
Sicherheitslage dort verstärkt die
Polizei ihre Einsatzkräfte ab morgen
sollen Reserveeinheiten der Grenzpolizei
in Stadtzentren eingesetzt werden
bei dem Anschlag in Tel Aviv gestern
Abend war ein italienischer Tourist
getötet worden und sieben weitere
Touristen wurden verletzt zuvor waren
bei einem Attentat im Westjordanland
zwei israelische Frauen umgekommen trotz
dieser Sicherheitslage haben heute Abend
wieder 10.000 Menschen gegen die
geplante Justizreform von
Ministerpräsidenten
der neue Bundeshaushalt steht noch nicht
und so wird in der Ampelkoalition weiter
über Milliarden diskutiert laut
Finanzminister Lindner klafft eine Lücke
von bis zu 18 Milliarden Euro und diese
Lücke so sagte er der Rheinischen Post
müsse durch Verzicht erwirtschaftet
werden die Koalitionspartner SPD und
Grüne reagierten reserviert Grünen
fraktions-
und sozialer Klimaschutz haben
mitten im Streit um
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche in den USA gibt
es dort eine weitere juristische
Auseinandersetzung in dieser Frage ein
Bundesgericht in Texas hat die
landesweite Zulassung einer der
gängigsten abtreibungspillen ausgesetzt
der als konservativ
geltendeck gab damit einer Klage von
Abtreibungsgegnern recht
US-Präsidentin Harris kritisierte die
Entscheidung ist bedrohe die Rechte von
Frauen im ganzen Land die Regierung
kündigte an Berufung einzulegen
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr zwei 16 26
34 40 49 Superzahl 3 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de
und im zdf-
der Blick aufs Wetter morgen teils ist
es stark bewölkt teils auch länger
freundlich vor allem in nieder- und
Oberbayern kann es Schauer geben die
Temperatur steigt auf Werte von 9 bis 16
Grad am Ostermontag gibt es für alle
Sonne und 14 bis 19 Grad ab Dienstag
wird es wieder unbeständig und sehr
windig dazu werden 10 bis 17 Grad
erreicht
wir haben diese Sendung mit dem Wunsch
nach Frieden begonnen und mit dem
russischen Krieg gegen die Ukraine wir
hören auf mit Erinnerungen an den
Künstler der nicht nur die ikonische
Friedenstaube erschaffen hat sondern
auch das berühmteste
anti-kriegsgemälde gerne der überhaupt
wohl berühmteste Künstler des 20
Jahrhunderts heute vor 50 Jahren ist
Pablo Picasso gestorben anders für mehr
als 50 Ausstellungen auf der ganzen Welt
davon allein 16 in seinem Geburtsland
Spanien
insbesondere die andalusische Metropole
Malaga feiert ihren Picasso weil er ihr
hilft sich als Kulturstadt neu zu
erfinden und die Touristen bleiben
sollen und nicht gleich weiter an den
Strand aus Malaga
als hätte er schon mit sieben Jahren
gewusst dass aus ihm ein großer
vielleicht sogar der bekannteste Maler
der Welt werden würde gewohnt
selbstbewusst eindringlich sein Blick
auf den ersten Fotos im Geburtshaus von
Pablo Picasso seine erste Erinnerung sei
das Licht von Malaga schrieb er später
und dieses Licht seiner Arbeit sein
Leben hier entdeckt der Junge Pablo auch
seine Liebe für den Stierkampf
die Tiere waren in seinem Leben immer
präsent er hat sie sehr mit Malaga
verbunden und mit Dingen hier
verflochten der Stierkampf aber auch der
Stier an sich als klassische Figur das
erlebte er hier mit vier Jahren als er
seinen ersten Stierkampf gesehen hat
zusammen mit seinem Vater und seinem
Onkel
mit Anfang 20 verließ Picasso Spanien
das Franco Regime erklärte ihn später
zum Staatsfeind der behielt seine
spanische Staatsangehörigkeit aber kam
nie wieder in sein Heimatland zurück
hier in Andalusien hat Picasso nur
wenige Spuren hinterlassen die meisten
seiner über 50.000 Werke sind in
Frankreich entstanden was im
Picasso-Museum von Malaga zu sehen ist
kommt größtenteils von der Stiftung
seiner Nachkommen die Stadt bemüht sich
nun ihren verlorenen Sohn heimzuholen
ich weiß viel über Picasso weil es in
Paris das Picasso Museum gibt ich habe
auch das Picasso Museum in Barcelona
besucht aber ich wusste nicht dass
Malaga seine Geburtsstadt ist
ich habe hier das erste Mal wirklich
etwas über seine Kindheit gelernt und
was ihn geformt hat
Picasso als kulturelles Markenzeichen
zum 50 Todestag sollen Kunst und Kultur
in der andalusischen Hafenstadt im
Mittelpunkt stehen und nicht mehr so
sehr der Strand Massentourismus maria
palomeres ist in Malaga aufgewachsen und
macht Führungen durch die Altstadt
vorbei an Orten die alle irgendetwas mit
Pablo Picasso zu tun haben
um zu plaudern im Hinterzimmer
war hier früher eine Bar oder so etwas
nein nein das war schon immer eine
Apotheke
in Malaga gibt es keine Unbekannten oder
versteckten Bilder von Picasso zu
entdecken dafür die Kirche in der er
getauft wurde oder den Innenhof seiner
Grundschule
ein halbes Jahrhundert nach seinem Tod
wird Pablo Picasso in Spanien als
staatsheld gefeiert er selbst war bis zu
seinem Lebensende nur noch in Gedanken
hier
der weltweite Picasso Boom funktioniert
auch deshalb so gut weil der Meister
unfassbar fleißig war der französische
Staat hatte 1974 mal begonnen Picassos
schaffen systematisch zu erfassen und
brauchte dafür 7 Jahre
freuen Sie sich auf die Kollegin Dunja
Hayali gleich im auslandsjournal gleich
nach uns und dann ab morgen hier an
dieser Stelle und gegen 0 25 gibt's die
nächste heute Express wir verabschieden
uns von ihnen mit besten Wünschen
tschüss wiedersehen
[Musik]